[Music]
we can't show them this captain I don't
see the problem but it's got the the
deep ocean as my grandfather Jacques
Cousteau probably said is dark and full
of mysteries none more important to us
humans than how we went from this to
this this is the acorn worm they have no
eyes no brain no sense organs and
subsist mostly on a diet of well dirt
they're also the link between
vertebrates and invertebrates
approximately 70% of our genes trace
their ancestry back to the acorn worm
fascinating this phallus shaped worm was
discovered in the Burgess Shale in
Canada's Yoho National Park almost a
hundred years ago the fossil went
unnoticed until hold on John Boehner
how's it hanging what's wrong Philippe
all is well thank you how did you find
that warm again
I was at the Smithsonian DC taking a
closer look at their workforce
collection from the first shell and
using modern technology I managed to
find that some of these wounds belong to
a group called the acorn warm and I said
oh my gosh this one really connects a
lot of vibration dots in this Roman
almost mentioned for more than 500
million years till 500 million years has
sank well we think that at some point
the eccrine warm upon their habitat and
opted instead to dig into the sediment
and eat mud
good day thanks jungle now the acorn
worm the missing link between
vertebrates and invertebrates without
which we might all still be eating dirt
give it a try I hear it builds the
immune system Captain's Log we find
ourselves in the Aegean Sea near
Greece's 4na archipelago an underwater
archaeologists dream come true I imagine
a predecessors ancient seafarers with an
unparalleled and profound sense of
adventure you're doing it again love oh
sorry
[Music]
we're here about 12 miles from the coast
of Greece where a group of scientists
uncovered 22 different shipwrecks late
last year all in an area of only 17
square miles that's smaller than the
island of Manhattan
speaking of Manhattan's next time Brian
easy on the bitters some of these ships
date back over 2500 years and while most
of the vessels are unrecognizable after
25 centuries of oceanic decay these
underwater archaeologists found some
pretty incredible artifacts thank you
much better on the bidders Brian and
what do you think should we call Peter
Peter how goes it
find any ancient artifacts yet today
hello Philippe we actually came across
another 23 shipwrecks at the 40
archipelago July 2016 no ship hardly
with 45 ships in fact over the course of
these explorations we found pots and
ceramics that haven't been found on
shipwrecks before
in these islands were an important
navigational channel the large volume of
ship traffic in every time period and
these ships were they fully loaded yes
you could say that
thanks very much Peter you heard the man
no time to waste there must be more
priceless trip antiquities around here
somewhere
oh sure nuts engaged
[Music]
[Music]
where is it
I put it over there by the couch an
electric eel magnificent
[Music]
our submarine is docked here in the
Amazon River we could have gone to the
Orinoco River but our dear Desiree
wouldn't fit this is the only other
place in the world to find electric eels
except Amol Shelly electric eels are
quite the peculiar species they're like
aquatic batteries the majority of their
body is made up of organs that produce
electricity
less'n you can hear it they're also
obligate air breathers which means they
must surface every 10 minutes or so to
breathe above water scientists at
Vanderbilt University no hold on let's
get kenneth on the line what role
Kenneth so I hear your team has some
interesting findings eh yeah we
discovered something really remarkable
so when you threaten or corner an
electric eel it can leap out of the
water and put its chin onto you
so that the current is sent straight
through your body and back down to the
water giving maximal shock how shocking
now how do these eels generate all that
electricity well they have modified
muscles that in the course of evolution
are now just used to generate
electricity and they line these up in
series to generate high voltages and
create a very powerful shock
thanks getteth and say hi to the missus
for me okay
these eels might be dangerous but once
they shock their prey they need time to
recharge so you probably won't get
shocked are we safe there's no cover on
the tank yeah sure
[Music]
like my grandfather Jacques Cousteau
used to say the impossible missions are
the only ones that succeed and before
humankind had explored the moon my
family set out to explore the sea that's
why they launched the continental shelf
initiative a series of underwater
research laboratories the likes of which
the world had never seen
[Music]
in 1960 my grandfather
joined by my father philippe senior set
out to build an underwater research
station for their growing team of osha
knots they were kind of like you guys
two years later Conshelf was dropped at
a depth of about 30 feet off the coast
of mel say a yellow steel cylinder 16
feet long and 8 feet in diameter it
served as a home and lab for its two
inhabitants for a week a short time
later Conshelf 2 was dropped onto a reef
in the red sea where we find ourselves
today
[Music]
not only was Conshelf a research
platform for marine scientists it was
also a human experiment to test the
effects of isolation and sun deprivation
six oceanauts spent a month living at
depths of up to 82 feet nowadays
Conshelf - covered in coral and algae is
teeming with lionfish clownfish and
beautiful anemones the experiment proved
that explorers can live underwater for
protracted periods of time but that the
lack of sunlight made them a little bit
loopy
how long have we been down here I've
I've lost track
I guess you could say these submarines
are better suited for animals than
people we are people right
[Music]